hey guys pete here today i'm going to do
a breakdown of fargo season 4 episode 8.
i'm back as it were since i wasn't here
last week i had the flu
and it was mostly a setup episode and i
really wasn't into it all that much so
i decided to take the week off because
it was a setup i was really hoping that
i would get sucked back into it with
this episode right here
and it kind of didn't happen for me i
would say this probably was the best
episode of the season so far
and i know people enjoyed it so i don't
want to be too negative but for me while
it was fun to watch
it really didn't solve the problems that
have been going on throughout the season
i'll get to that at the end when i get
into the review part of it
before that i'm going to recap
everything that happened
and if you're here without watching
episode 8 yet then this is your spoiler
warning you don't want to do that if you
haven't watched the episode this video
will ruin it for you so hit the
subscribe button
go watch the episode get caught up and
then come back watch the recap and
review
and get involved in the conversation
down in the comments
the episode opens up with a reminder
that
josto is still gonna get married we see
him have dinner
with dessie his betrothed and melvin
her father that's all cut with him
hanging out with orienta which i guess
that's also still going on right
over the last few episodes this had all
been kind of pushed to the side
and now we know that he is in fact still
planning on getting married
although they don't have a date and now
orienta
also knows that this is his plan he
explains to her that it's just
business he's just doing it he's not in
love we get a little bit of backstory on
orienta
and her mother how she came to be a
nurse she says it was a calling
and that she was sick most of the time
when she was a child
she suffered from a kind of malaise the
doctor said a failure to thrive
it also sounds like this was related to
her mother giving her what she called
her special juice
it all sounds like munchausen syndrome
where her mother was keeping her sick
maybe for her attention maybe to keep
her
needing her whatever it was it probably
plays a role in her going out and
killing her own patients
after hearing this josto leaves the room
and while he's gone orienta takes the
opportunity to call the hospital to
check about dr harvard
she's expecting that he's dead like we
thought he would be dead but she finds
out he made a full recovery
so she has that on her mind as josto
tries to open up to her
he explains that his childhood was all
screwed up as well
he tells her about being traded to the
milligan family
how the dawn over there did things that
should never be done to a child
and he tells her that he loves her she
freaks out she doesn't seem to want to
hear about his childhood or the fact
that he's in love with her
and she basically just screams at him
and tells him to get out
he heads over to joplin's where he finds
out that gaetano
is there lloyd cannon didn't kill him he
actually let him go
and things go pretty badly at the
beginning he flips him over a table
he knocks him out but then when he comes
too gaetano pledges his loyalty to him
he basically says that he
is so proud of him for trying to have
loy
execute him for the retaliation for
killing satchel
he explains it all in like he's the lion
he's the muscle
the bull and josto is the snake he has
the strategy he even gets down
on one knee and pledges his allegiance
and it kind of all makes sense
last week when i was thinking about
loy's plan it didn't really seem like it
would be
easy to get these two to go against each
other while they squabbled
family was important and they are in a
bigger structure
where you know they can't really just
knock each other off that was the whole
reason why
josto was trying to use lloyd to get rid
of guytano in the first place
either way they're now a team that seems
to smooth over everything
but it was interesting that we see abel
in a shot where he's looking on
he doesn't quite look convinced there's
something going on with that it really
stood out i thought the way that they
focused in on him
so he may have his own plan but there's
something going on
and everything changes at the end of the
episode anyways
the word of them not killing each other
or not even going to war with each other
gets back to loy
and when he's presented with this it
sounds like he had a plan b
already to go and he just says fargo
which is a tie back
to them giving the machine guns to mort
kellerman
saying that he owed him loyalty after
the deal his wife goes over to the
funeral home
there's an exchange with dabrell and i
mean it seems like she's going over
there to talk to lemuel and she's also
going through this thing they think
satchel's dead
so she wants to sit down and talk to the
woman but she makes it clear up front
that she won't be able to help her
they still go through the motions of it
anyways and it's a pretty good scene
overall
i think the big thing here is though
that these two characters aren't that
developed so
while it's enjoyable to watch you still
kind of just scratch your head and think
how important are they to the rest of
the story upstairs we find ethel rita in
her room she's listening to records
and lemuel comes in and i'm not sure is
he actually staying inside the house or
is he just working there during the day
this is the second time we've seen these
two
sort of cross paths for all intents and
purposes it looks like there's a romance
budding
they sort of flirt they talk about
records they talk about jazz
they're interrupted by dubrell who tells
him that his mother's downstairs
and tells her that she needs to be
careful basically
he's your captor not your friend and
that sounds like pretty good advice
as he goes downstairs it seems pretty
obvious that she's about to deliver the
news about satchel
and then it just cuts away from there
orienta has taken herself to the
hospital and she basically finds out
that dr harvard's been
moved out of state they found out he was
poisoned by strychnine
and they take him away because there was
already the shootout out front
and now they know someone's trying to
poison him and they probably think it's
all connected
this is not really good news for her she
goes home and she looks like she's going
to leave town
she starts packing in the process of
that she finds ethel rita's journal in
her
closet and now those two are definitely
going to cross paths
she has the letter there so she compares
the handwriting she knows ethel rita
wrote it and we watch as she watches
ethel rita leave her house and there's
really no way that these two
aren't going to have a big showdown
duffy shows up at loy's house and he
wants to know where zelmer and swaney
are
this is probably the best back and forth
i think in this episode
lloyd says that he is accountable he
promised that no harm would come to them
and duffy turns it around saying that
you know by
his nature he can't be accountable
criminals reject morality
and ethics and their existence is fueled
by
not being accountable so they have this
other system that they create that's
based on loyalty
and i thought this was fun to watch
lloyd briefly tries to
tell him about all the good he does in
his community and
duffy basically just laughs it off
eventually lloyd gives up that they're
going to be on the 10 o'clock train
and then he threatens deffy on the way
out the door
back at the police station he sets up a
plan to go
catch them otis is on the phone while
he's talking
and he sees that this leads to a
conversation
where otis says that he really wants to
be a cop again he wants to be a good cop
he gives us some backstory and it's okay
it kind of contradicts the whole idea of
him going to the war
and losing his fiancee to this violent
end
but it's whatever i guess basically he
liked being a cop because it gave him
power
his ocd didn't act up as much whenever
he had that going on
having to work with the criminals and
being compromised
led him to feeling more powerless and so
he's able to sell it basically that he's
on deffi's side at this point
the whole thing goes down at the train
station
led by the marshall the troops head in
otis is stuck in the car
he can't quite get out we see a somewhat
sweet moment
with swanny and zelmaire getting ready
to leave town
and then we see mr snowman make an
appearance the ghost
which it seems like that sets zelmer to
start scanning the crowd to see what's
going
on and she sees deffy which gives them
the drop
and a shootout erupts although most of
it happens off-screen
otis finally makes it out of the car he
shows up late
as he comes in we see that there are a
ton of
innocent people dead to go along with
the cops
any sort of likeability that the outlaws
had banked
sort of goes out the window at this
point otis
catches up with them just after deffy
does and they basically run out of
bullets and have nowhere to go
when he's asked to cuff them instead
otis shoots
deffy and then shoots swanny but then he
pauses for a second which is all
zelmer needs to sort of rush him and he
misses the shot for her
she escapes otis is kind of paralyzed he
can't really chase after in the moment
and probably the best touch of the
entire scene is
the look on deffy's dead face it's like
he's stuck in a
i can't believe you just did that kind
of accusing kind of stare on his face
back at the fada house josto and his
guys are out in the backyard
guy tano comes out telling him to take a
drink and
ask him about constant she also explains
that he's out
searching for rabbi and satchel their
mom briefly tries to get them to come
back inside
and then mort kellerman and the fargo
gangsters
show up in the backyard and start
opening fire they killed just about
everyone except
for the two brothers gaetano makes a
crazy
charge taking a couple of them out in
the process
it doesn't seem like the smartest thing
but it works out
josto was able to hide and then they
hear a scream inside
they go in and they find out that their
mother has been killed by a stray bullet
there's another body there as well i
wasn't able to make out if that's their
sister
or someone else but i guess what's
really important here is that their
mother has been
killed and that's something they're
gonna have to retaliate for
there's no way that the war does not
escalate new york would never stop them
for
going after the people who killed their
mother so at the end of the episode we
can finally say that there is
no way that they're gonna get out of
doing that
so yeah like i said i think this
probably is the best episode
as a standalone saying it moved a lot
better than some of these
previous episodes had done at the train
station the tension was good
but overall to me it still feels like a
bunch of
stories that are happening next to each
other instead of all being woven
together
ethel rita has had like one single scene
in the last few episodes
so even though that's set up for her and
orienta to come
head to head it's just not really the
center of the story
you kill off daffy here it makes sense
but when i think about that scene you
know you have otis standing there
looking at
zelmer swanny and deffy otis is not the
one that i want to be
left alive at the end to me he's the
least interesting of those four
characters and
it seems like he's the most important
one zelmer will obviously
do something i mean she has to be going
for loy he's the only one that would
have been able to give that information
up but after seeing them mow down
all these innocent bystanders we're not
really rooting for her
so yeah like i said i don't think this
really solved the problems that i was
having with the season
as i mentioned a few episodes back i'm
gonna keep watching
even when it's not totally working
there's enough about it that i'm gonna
keep coming back to see what happens
next but i've kind of lost
hope that it's all going to come
together in this really great
climax it just doesn't have momentum at
this point
i have watched the preview for the next
episode and it looks like it has some
potential to be
an interesting standalone kind of thing
but i mean i'm not going to get into all
that right now
i don't really know where it's going i
don't imagine that many of these
characters will survive
and i'm not even sure who i would choose
besides ethel rita to make it out like
it seems like they're putting ethel rita
together with
lemuel and if that's the case that
there's a setup there i hope they really
do kind of flush these two characters
out a little bit
to make us care so rip deffi rip swanny
cap it's like a who's who of all the
best characters
if orienta dies in the next episode then
it really would be
confounding he had dr senator go first
then deffy then swanny i mean they're
kind of killing off the best characters
but let me know what you think in the
comments what are you hoping to see
happen by the end do you think it's just
a mike milligan
origin story or do you think that there
is
something else up their sleeve please
like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon